ah the coffee's kicking in
[Music]
there's a tempo to life there's a tempo
to every song you can lift the band and
the band can lift you in the beatles it
was like being psychic
we knew what to do we loved to do it
with each other
best band i ever was in
i love to play i love to sit behind
those boogers
it fills a lot of my soul
you know the way i play is sort of a
purposeful way
when it gets to the chorus go to the
bell
i still do to this day because it raises
it up
[Music]
you're gonna work for the verses the
chorus you can rock
with the bass drum once i've hit it
that's what i've done
some people like
deaden it
off
off
the dream of being a drummer came when i
was 13.
i was in hospital i had tuberculosis
to keep us busy
a music lady would come in with
percussion things maracas triangles she
gave me a little teeny drum the first
time she came in
and
something came over me that i knew this
is what i want to do
if i can give you anything to take away
you just got to love what you're doing
and you've got to do it your way
it doesn't matter if there's 40 000
or 40 people
you've just got to get yourself some
friends and play
the more you play the better life is
i'm ringo starr and this is masterclass
[Music]
you